the One Piece manga just revealed three
things that no one expected the ancient
robot from the void Century attacked the
celestial dragons just 200 years ago
Vega Punk has possibly the most OP devil
fruit in the story and it looks like the
genius scientist will also join the
straw hats on their ship once they leave
Egghead Islands but How likely is that
actually well as we'll see really not
all that unlikely at all and why does
vega Punk want to leave this place well
eckhead Island seems incredibly small
compared to most of the islands that
we've been to recently George Rosa had
an entire city on it totland was a whole
archipelago and wano multiple Islands
mush together so eckhead Island really
looks tiny in comparison it's really
only vegapung's giant lab and a bit of
greenery around it but despite its size
it's an island that seems to hold way
more importance than almost any other
place the straw hats have gone to it's
filled to the brim with the most
advanced technology in existing is right
now holding all the knowledge remaining
from the ancient Kingdom it's the place
where pretty much all the major
technological advancement for the
government have been created including
the pacifista and the seraphim in other
words it's the island that holds pretty
much all of vegapunk's research and
knowledge so why would he want to go
away from there oh because it turns out
that this island isn't only vegapung's
base of operation but in a way a part of
himself because the manga has now
revealed that the scientist is actually
a devil fruit user which does explain
his ridiculously large hat in a very
reassuring way vegapunk has eaten the
brain brain food which in Japanese is
named the nominomi Nomi which is
hilarious objectively but Oda really had
to jump through some hoops to make this
one work you see brain in Japanese is
null and brains is having brains being
smart is called nomiso so Oda really
just decided to cut out the zoo and get
his nomi nomi nomi which is incredible
be funny and one of those puns that just
only work in Japanese now it seems that
this fruit's ability isn't High
Intelligence however apparently vegapung
was born a Real Genius instead the fruit
allows its user to store and remember
any type of knowledge down to the very
last detail that means that anything you
want to learn you will know by heart in
an instance you always have access to
all of your knowledge at all time and
you never forget anything now a side
effect of this fruit is that one's brain
needs to keep growing the more knowledge
one acquires you know in order to keep
up with all that data thus Vega Punk's
very bizarre appearance now before we
can discuss what that has to do with
vegapunk wanting to sail away with Luffy
I think we have to discuss this fruit in
more detail first because this ability
is just absolutely
overpowered there's really no other way
of saying it if you have the ability to
learn anything you want without ever
forgetting any of it this would make you
the most powerful person on the planet
in no time now maybe you could say oh
knowing stuff doesn't mean you can
actually do anything against someone
like Blackbeard with this Guru guranomi
or the darkness fruit but that's just
not true I mean just look at vegapunk
using his powers he has deciphered all
the knowledge available from the ancient
Kingdom he has created giant robots
laser weapons he has discovered how to
use C prism stone to nullify devil fruit
powers and he can literally clone devil
fruits in other words if vegapunk really
wanted he could just build an army of
seraphim for himself and take over the
world really when you've read every
strategy and psychology book in
existence when you know everything that
is to know about anyone out there in my
eyes this makes you pretty close to
Invincible a god even if you want
knowledge is power as they like to say
and vegapunk is already intelligent and
has exclusive access to Advanced
knowledge which makes his fruit even
more potent than it would already be if
let's say someone like Luffy ate it I
mean this man has literally managed to
create alter egos connected to a central
brain in fact when you really think
about just how strong this fruit makes
him I'm really wondering how Oda will
nerf it because let's be real he will
have to I mean why work with the
government at this point if you could
just overthrow them with your own
technology we already know that vegapunk
seems to share the same cause as Dragon
so the only explanation I have for this
right now really is that the government
has something up its sleeve that
vegapunk just can't go up against openly
like either they have a way to hold him
hostage in a way which would be
incredibly effective even with someone
as powerful as him or another
explanation might be that the gurose and
emu have access to ancient technology
even more advanced than vegapunks you
know the type of technology that allowed
them to overthrow the technologically
advanced ancient Kingdom in the first
place I mean if you have any ideas about
this I would love to hear them because
presented with its powers the nomi nomi
nomi does sound like the most powerful
devil fruit in existence now really I'm
only curious if vegapunk could clone his
nominominomi to make more nominomi Nomis
and give each of those clones of his
anomino me as well to multiply the
effect and yeah I did that on purpose
but it was kind of fun to say but maybe
this immense power is exactly the reason
why the government is now coming for his
head because they fear that he could
actually surpass them anyways as a side
effect of consuming the entirety of the
library of ahara and all the knowledge
stored inside it vegapunk's brain has
grown too large to carry around with him
any longer you know what maybe that was
the original weak point of this fruit
that at some point it would just break
your neck or Crush its user under its
own weight but vegapunk found a way to
separate his brain and connect himself
and all of his alter egos remotely to
that Central Hub and so the at this
point unfathomably large Brain is
incorporated into the upper levels of
his lab labeled as the punk records
vigapunk actually dreams of connecting
every single person in the world to this
pool of knowledge which does sound like
a nice idea kind of like the internet of
the one piece World however jimbei
raises some really important privacy
concerns here because I mean giving
everyone access to Mega Punk's brain
like the other Vega punks would that
turn everyone into a vegapunk it would
also mean everyone would know everything
about everyone all the time which does
sound a little bit like uh Black Mirror
episode if you ask me now vegapunk just
sweeps this common aside saying that
science needs to keep advancing and I
think that this right here might hint at
vegapung's biggest character flaw in
general he puts scientific Advance over
his morality I mean clearly vegapunk in
a way agrees with dragon's plans and
dislikes the government but getting
funding for his research was apparently
more important to him similarly he
is a judge and queen were conducting
ethically Highly Questionable research
on humans and prisoners killing many and
disfiguring others I mean look at the
emotionless Vince MC family or the
Giants on Punk Hazard I really do not
think that vegapunk is a bad guy at
heart but his priorities make him a
quite morally ambiguous character same
as the people you know who watch this
video up to this point but haven't
subscribed to the channel yet now of
course all of this would fit in really
nicely with the reveal that vegapunk is
also a perfectionist he deemed Momos
devil fruit a failure because the colors
didn't match or the lightsaber that
actually freaking works like the ones in
Star Wars because they also attract bugs
I mean that's just crazy but once again
you can kind of see that this is a guy
who would put his ethics aside to bring
a research project to its Perfection and
really when you think about it I think
it takes a slightly messed up person to
even bear not forgetting anything in the
first place this is really another draw
back of the fruit our brains are
actually hardwired to process and forget
about traumatic and hurtful events in
our life so just imagine that you could
never forget any accident or terrible
thing that ever happened in your entire
life instead you can always recall
anything any physical or mental pain you
ever felt in perfect detail that sounds
kind of unhealthy and in reality
probably would make life pretty much
unlivable I think what this means
however is that Egghead island is a
living part of vegapunk so why does he
ask Luffy to take him away well there's
a few possibilities maybe vegapung wants
to get back to elbeth where all of
O'Hara's knowledge is stored maybe he
wants to find dragon who is just
starting his big campaign with the
revolutionaries to help him in his fight
or maybe he's just fearing for his life
I mean genius that he is vegapunk might
already have figured out that the
government is coming for his head we've
already seen Chaka telling dragon that
he's expecting to die soon but is is it
realistic that we will leave Egghead
islands with vegapunk on boards maybe
even as the next Super unexpected straw
hats I think there are Arguments for
both sides here I think you can't really
argue that vegapunk wouldn't make a
wonderful addition to the crew traveling
to elbaf and finally love tail it might
even be his knowledge and his technology
that's the key to reaching love tale and
defeating the world's government it
would be helping the other strawheads
reach their full potential along the way
and it would also be a great way to have
Luffy and dragon reunite very soon too
however on the other hand you could also
argue that vegapunk knows way too much
and is way too powerful to be an actual
asset to Luffy I mean his knowledge
about the world would basically make
Robin and especially Frankie pretty much
redundant in a way and overall it might
just make the straw hats too powerful
going into the end game so instead
giving Luffy and Koh some information
and a couple of upgrades here or there
might be the safer route to go down for
odor ultimately having vegapunk actually
died during this Arc and dragon might be
coming for eckhead Island anyways I mean
the chapter strongly suggests that Kuma
is trying to save his daughter Bonnie
after Luchi announced that they would
kill her if they encountered her another
time and that she would be of no more
use to the government actually no
think about it maybe Bonnie was the
thing that the gurose used to Blackmail
Kuma and veg Punk with and it might also
mean that Kuma is actually also
connected to vegapunk's brain the secret
seventh clone I think this chapter
definitely gives us hope that we will
see Kuma regain his real personality
though especially since vegapong seems
to be very good with disconnecting
brains and keeping them functioning at a
different place now Kuma as a cyborg is
already pretty damn impressive as a
feature of engineering but not nearly as
impressive as the giant robot Soldier
located on the islands and the manga has
now finally confirmed that this is
actual technology from the void Century
however it's been active a lot lot more
recently than any of us could have
expected instead of just rusting away
sitting there for the past 800 years
apparently it climbed the red line in an
attempt to attack marijua 200 years ago
after it was then stopped by the
government the scientist has brought it
to Egghead Island to study it and as
expected it was the inspiration for the
giant robots that vegapunk has built as
well now this timing is fascinating for
a few reasons first someone actually
remembered how to use this technology
200 years ago and was able to use it
against the government second the
government was actually able to stop
this thing somehow before they had any
of vegapunk's current inventions and as
Robin reminds us it also fits in
perfectly with the timeline where the
fishmen were first acknowledged as
people and not Fish and were invited to
the reverie this is actually something
that Hachi tells us about way early in
the story now there are two other events
that take place 200 years ago that
random ship that fell from the sky had
made it to skypeia during that timeline
and the giant fighting fish appeared on
greenbid Andres Rosa could all of these
events be connected really there is no
way of telling right now but what Oda
seems to be be suggesting or at least
wants us to believe is that the fishmen
were the ones who sent the giant robot
to attack the world government in order
to gain more rights I guess and if
that's actually true Fisher tiger
another Fishman might have been the
ultimate foreshadowing for this I mean
maybe he was even inspired by his
ancestors to climb the red line himself
I'm really incredibly curious about what
really happened here but I do also want
to talk about the robot's mysterious
power source because it's the second
time now that a vegapunk mentions a
limitless energy source an eternal flame
of swords that was apparently used to
power these giant machines I think I've
seen some people suggest that it might
be Frankie's Cola technology however as
we've seen more than once it's neither
Limitless nor exactly convenient to use
instead it does kind of look like the
robot has a giant furnace in its belly
and the idea of an eternal flame does
sound a little bit like something that
we are actually currently working on
here on Earth now you probably aware
that nuclear power is splitting atoms
and then releasing the energy stored
inside the bonds which does create a lot
of dangerous radioactive waste in the
process however you can do this process
in Reverse to create a lot more clean
energy by combining lighter atoms into
heavier ones under a lot of heat this
process is called nuclear fusion and
it's basically how Stars work so our sun
technically is a Giant floating Fusion
reactor and that technology actually
exists even if it's not quite yet ready
for actual use but since nuclear fusion
is also referred to as the sun in a
bottle that really made my alarm bells
ring with the entire story of sangod
Nika lately I mean Luffy's firepowers
and the Nika fruits connection to the
ancient Kingdom and joy boy maybe one of
the technologies that the ancient
Kingdom used was nuclear fusion or the
powers directly from the Sun Sun God's
devil fruit but really this is only one
of the many lost Technologies from the
avoid centuries that have completely
changed how we look at the one piece
world and the story overall and I broke
all of it down in this video right here
if you want to watch a little bit longer